as russell wilson and the seattle
seahawks is kyle murray and the arizona
cardinals kyler's got zero super bowl
wins in part because he has zero playoff
appearances he's only been in the league
two years but the clock is ticking on
kyler murray and he spoke to reporters
yesterday and look
let's just hear what he said and i'll
talk more about it later because i got
some thoughts on this here's kyler
murray bringing up the reality that this
football star would still very much like
to play a little baseball here he is
the day came where i you know i got to
do what i wanted to do
which i don't know you know i'm leaving
it open but
um
no yeah i think you know i just i think
i can still play for sure the next
contract will you
work that in and and how serious are you
about maybe someday doing
all three
i mean uh
yeah i know i know everybody around like
around here probably you know feels
different about it but i mean me
personally like i
i played the game my whole life like if
i had if i ever had the opportunity for
sure like i would i would definitely go
for it like that's
what are we talking about
and i'm sure any anybody else asking me
would too so
i don't know i'm not trying to start
anything i'm just talking
yeah it's funny the cardinals fans
seized on that line to shout down
any effort to
talk about write about
interpret what he was saying oh he said
i'm not trying to start anything i'm
just talking well sometimes when you're
just talking you start something and
sometimes that something's already
started it predates his arrival to the
nfl miles he was a top 10 pick the
oakland a's he can go play baseball
anytime he wants he has the one thing
that
99.9999
of pro football players don't have and
that is an option to play another
professional sport at a high level and
get paid accordingly for most pro
football players this is the only place
they're going to get that money that
they're making kyle murray can say see
you later i'll go play baseball that
becomes a valuable tool for him when
it's time to receive offers from the
cardinals when it's time to deal with a
franchise tag if it gets to that point
oh they applied the franchise tag well
i'll just go play baseball i'm not under
contract i can go play baseball they
can't tell me not to i'm gonna play
baseball from february until august and
then maybe i'll sign the franchise tag
and show up for week one he can do that
if he wants to and as we see this push
to minimize the significance of the off
season program
if that
continues
why not have a guy say one day hey
i can do it i don't i don't need to you
know i'll go play baseball i'll study my
playbook at night we can do some zoom
calls at night you cater to me i'm the
starting quarterback but
i think that it's not going away
and as he gets closer and closer to the
end of his rookie contract it becomes a
very powerful leverage point for him
to get what he wants russell wilson uses
that we hear about baseball every every
time
it's time for him to negotiate a new
contract
well calamari is a hell of a lot better
baseball player than russell wilson ever
will be kyle murray's got a real option
if he wants to play baseball and it
seems like he wants to do it i can't
rule it out and i don't think he should
either
i don't think you should rule it out but
i also feel like if you're the arizona
cardinals at some point and if he
actually does bring this up in a
negotiation or something like that you
might want to call his bluff because
frankly he hasn't really played baseball
in a while now i mean it's been a couple
years at least right and you know when
you're talking about somebody who is
dedicated his wife to being a
quarterback and being a great
quarterback then you've got to pick up
those baseball skills at some point and
i'm not saying that i don't think he can
but i also don't think it's like if kyle
murray says okay i'm gonna go play
baseball then he's immediately gonna go
be the starting center fielder for the
oakland ace right like that's not a
thing that's gonna happen you'd have to
at least go get some at bats somewhere
else so that he gets ready for it and
that's something that you can obviously
do i mean if it's he decides that it's
going to do it in february well then you
got all spring training to get yourself
ready and maybe you just see that hey
like he can really do this he can come
up to the majors and about like 250 get
on base at like a 350 clip and be good
enough that you can play him every day
but i think it's at least a very
interesting conversation that he brings
up even though he says he's just talking
right i if you are that good as a
quarterback and you are the centerpiece
of the franchise which you are if you
are a franchise qb
then
you are going to have to exhibit or
utilize i guess i should say every bit
of leverage that you can in order to get
as much money that you can and this is
one piece of that
first of all how dare you
how dare you how dare you underestimate
the ability of a baseball player
to to pick it up later in life
and
nearly get
to the major leagues how dare you
overlook the fact that we recently had a
guy who hadn't played baseball since
high school
who had a dream
he indulged that dream
and he made his way
through the new york mets farm system
based solely on merit and nothing else
from class a to double a to aaa on the
verge of making it to the show miles he
was there
and he decided it was time to retire
he decided he had other things that he
wanted to do how dare you think that
kyler murray couldn't do the same thing
i didn't say i didn't think you could do
it i just think that it would it
wouldn't be as immediate and like if you
want to play baseball that badly i mean
you know maybe maybe kyle murray can go
and play baseball and then he comes back
and he says actually i want to be a
tight end for the jacksonville
that would be a real story there
wouldn't it
it's a lot easier to beat the
linebackers when you're a tight end if
you can actually run through their legs
so
he could be very effective at the tight
end position um look i i i just think
that that he has
in his arsenal when it's time to
negotiate something that others don't
and it's real and and you know what
makes it even more persuasive it's i
don't think it's leverage i think he
wants to do it he really wants to do it
he wants to show he can do it deon
sanders did it brian jordan did it until
he picked baseball over football hey
look miles i'm a football guy through
and through but i've always said if
you've got the skills to play baseball
or basketball instead you should
because your body's going to come out of
it a hell of a lot less mangled
especially if it's baseball you're going
to play longer jeff samarjah
he was a notre dame receiver regarded as
a first round prospect 2007 he chose
baseball instead calvin johnson played
football same draft year 2007. samaritan
played longer and made more than calvin
johnson
because they've got those guaranteed
contracts yeah if you are a top tier
baseball player you're looking at a
guaranteed 300 million dollar contract
at this point if not more than that
right i mean i don't i mean francisco
lindor i think just got over 300 million
for the mets and like he's finally
starting to hit but before that he was
batting like 190 something so
you can make a lot of really good money
if you are a baseball player right and i
think that from that standpoint yeah if
you have those skills to be a top tier
guy which kyler murray does because he
was a top 10 pick in baseball then yeah
it's something that you should
definitely consider but i do i think it
would be really cool if you know the a's
so traded the kyler murray writes to uh
the arizona diamondbacks and then like
maybe one day you see that kyler murray
is doing stuff in otas or meeting camp
and then he gets in his car he drives
down to whatever they call the
diamondbacks field now chase field or
whatever it is and then he gets out and
then he like goes and starts in center
field because he's a two sport athlete
like that's fun
i was back
in 1992 when you were a year old there
he is there he is oh oh
come on one more try come on
fall down
go boom i was at the game when deion
sanders showed up and played for the
braves after playing earlier that day in
the nfl so
and that that's one last point on this
bo jackson played for the royals the
full season and then showed up with the
raiders after baseball was done
there's enough overlap where you got to
be
fully committed to one or the other one
of the others got to take precedence
one's got to be rock paper scissors over
the other and if you're a quarterback
it's kind of hard to
to show up in mid-october and say hey
here i am
let's go you ready let's go so it would
have to be baseball willing to take him
on a part-time basis and have him
disappear
just as the season is you know reaching
the stretch run i i don't know how
interested a a baseball team would be in
that miles well if they're terrible all
right you know if you're going to go 50
and 100 and what's the match
yeah yeah exactly the mets could have
them you know the diamondbacks i don't
think are are they good i actually don't
know i think the giants were in first
place the last time i checked the mets
are good the mets apparently are good
now okay
for the first time in 50 years the mets
are good sorry
sorry we've made a touchdown
i hope you guys weren't you know
expecting us to really know all that
much about baseball because clearly we
don't yeah it's playoff basketball time
so baseball is like way down on my
priority list
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports